hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to reading your
comments below you should make a vlog of
working out also I would love to hear
you sing have yourself a merry little
Christmas it would fit your voice very
well Abdur cellphone merry little
christmas something else for you mark
every now and then you've said that you
watch YouTube poops what's your favorite
poop well it's hard to remember
specifically what youtube poop is my
favorite because they kind of all blur
together but any of the king of the hill
YouTube poops are amazing but my
favorite is probably one of the old DBZ
poops way before they were even called
YouTube poops it's one that made over
9000 famous actually it's not even that
one that's not my favorite it's my
favorite is the what we're go to is
constantly now he's really getting huge
like up it's just really stupid because
well I mean it's YouTube poops so
obviously it's stupid but you guys kind
of watch I'll put a link right here so
you could see it okay cool I'm gonna
crack up if Mark ends up looking like
vanoss when he works out good thing he's
starting get some weightlifting and
push-ups in between you and gaming
that's what I do
I'm Vale gaming Morgan a have you ever
seen van Austin me in the same place at
the same time that's what I thought oh
you have oh hey Mark how high is your IQ
I would guess at least over 80 thanks
for giving me a lot of wiggle room on
that one that really makes me feel so
much better
I've never actually taken an official IQ
test so I have no interest of knowing
because then it would actually put a
number to how stupid I actually am so
I'm not gonna find out let's just assume
I belong in Mensa or I'm literally
Forrest Gump but hey Forrest Gump
accomplished a lot so like he's nothing
do the squats for the potatoes make
mother russia proud
Oh mark do you want to RP sure I'd love
to roleplay I can be Santa and you can
be who's your favorite character from
huniepop uh I don't know if I have a
favorite uh given that they're all anime
characters not real and that my decision
does not reflect in any way my
personality in any way I have to go say
his last because something about big
blue aliens it's really good for me to
have hey mark when are you gonna
continue undertale I'm just wondering I
I answered this a little bit ago because
I was tired of everyone in every video
constantly asking me where undertale is
it was the victim of unfortunate timing
there was a lot of things going on in my
life and then you know man Ryan came
back and then it got pushed to the
backburner but I am going to play
undertale very soon you are gonna see
something very substantial very soon and
don't get me wrong
I love the game it's not that I stopped
playing because I didn't like the game
it's I stopped playing because I didn't
know if I was playing the game for the
right reasons because I actually spoke
with it like a friend of the developer
of the game and you know I spoke with
Barry in the game grumps and everyone
else my friends that we play the game
and they all told me about how great the
game was but I always felt that people
were ignoring the genocide side of the
game and personally I wanted to
experience that because I have a little
bit you know it's weird I kind of want
to experience some of the tragedy that
has you know there is to offer but also
people were right in saying that I can't
have the full effect of the tragedy
unless I'm attached to the characters so
what I want to do is I want to do a full
huge many hour-long mega episode of the
pacifist playthrough that's all going to
be in one video huge like 6 hours long
however long it takes and then I'm going
to do another video where I just do the
genocide route and then there'll be two
videos one for the pacifist one for the
genocide like the pacifist first then do
the genocide and that way it's all out
in the open you guys can enjoy for what
it is and you don't have to wait much
longer so I'm gonna do my best I'm gonna
get to that
when I can it'll be soon hopefully by
the end of this week everyone happy go
do the Christmas okay yeah you liked at
Christmas Santa's gonna come down your
stocking and both its mark how do you do
the sex well it's something
here this is how you do the thing good
bark yay mark can you make the most MLG
10 seconds ever all right yeah you like
that Christmas yeah dureena husband
doing Ted 10:10 Christmas doing sex yeah
I feel you should create a bloopers
video like make a video with all the
hilarious outtakes that don't make it in
the official videos that you post while
he is in the normal gameplay videos I
don't have any bloopers because I just
put all my mistakes in because I'm too
lazy to cut them out but I do make a lot
of blooper videos for the other sketches
that we do we put them out all the time
here are some links like down in the
description below to the various
bloopers some of them were probably even
unlisted so there you go since you're
half Korean will you ever try to visit
Seoul or anywhere else in Korea uh yeah
I am half Korean and I have a lot of
family that lives in Korea I've been
there about I think four times the first
time I went I was too young to really
remember it but I went a few other times
and it was really cool to see how Korea
developed over time because I'll
describe it the weird way that it
developed because the first time I went
my grandparents had a house and it was
like in the middle of you know farmland
your mud roads and stuff like that and
then you know every time that I went
after the city that he was on the
outskirts of just kept growing bigger
and bigger I came there in like five
year intervals and bigger and bigger to
the point where suddenly there was like
pollution everywhere in this cars
everywhere and everything's a paved road
so yeah I'd like to go back to Korea
someday because uh I want to learn
Korean just so I can talk to my family
because I've got like seven ons some of
which are married a giant number of
cousins you know my grandma is still
there and there's a lot of people that
you know know that I'm doing YouTube now
so hi family in Korea if you're watching
this hello how are you doing shout out
to you alright hey Mark I really need
you to see this you've done more for me
than I can ever tell you your videos
have helped me get through
one of the toughest times in my life and
I carry your message around with me
every day on my arm in the form of a
pink moustache tattoo thank you for all
you do well thank you for that that's
amazing you have an actual pink
moustache tattoo on your arm I hope the
message that I'm giving guys is good and
and most of the time the message that I
give is that I just believe that you
guys can do whatever it is you want to
do because I'm sitting here in a stupid
room playing stupid games making stupid
videos but I also love the idea that I
you know I put out a message of goodwill
and hope that you guys take it up and
you spread a little good in the world
and do do some charity now and then and
try to help your fellow person out there
and that's really what's important to me
so it's good to know that people take it
to heart so thank you Jordan Hill for
doing that and thank you everyone else
who who carries around that message and
it's not really even my message it's
just a message of goodwill that you know
the world can be a better place and I'm
really happy that I get to do what I do
every day I'm happy that I get to make
videos that make other people happy
that's the main point of joy in my life
and that's why I'm so passionate about
what I do and I'm passionate about what
I do in that I have to enjoy what I do
or else I wouldn't do it but I don't
think I'm ever not going to be happy
that I get to do this and make people
out there laugh and make people out
there smile and inspire people to do
some good that's so important to me and
I'm glad that it's important to you guys
out there so thank you very much
listening to me that's all really mark
will you ever continue making your
American history lessons yes I
definitely plan to do more of those
because that was something that was
going to be the start of a project if
you guys don't know what he's talking
about he's talking about my fourth of
July a markiplier history lesson which
is a totally true telling of what
history was all about for the 4th of
July and also there was an animation
made for my Thanksgiving or know when
Thanksgiving when the pilgrims first
arrived in America like that's that that
was another thing because an animation
made about that all the police in the
description as well but there was a
whole big thing and I was gonna make a
big series out of it but other stuff got
in the way I'm only one guy I I didn't
have a lot of time so I'm hoping now
that I have you know my friends helping
me that I'm gonna have a lot more time
to do the things that I want to do and
do the things that are more amazing than
just Let's Plays you know I say amazing
it's not amazing but more interesting
than Let's Plays all the time not that
I'm never gonna slow down on Let's Plays
you know some people were worried about
that just cuz I'm doing more scheduling
all right where are the gameplays like
it please still come but don't worry
about I mean always gonna do that but I
always like to mix in more things
because when I went on YouTube what I
originally wanted to do was sketch
videos so the mixture of the two and
constantly doing new things is what
really inspires me to do more creatively
so so long as I'm always pushing myself
to do more self creatively I'm never
gonna get bored with what I do here and
I'm never gonna get bored with the fact
that people enjoy what I make so that's
really cool any more impossible Let's
Plays plans yes in addition to the other
things same spiel I have a lot of stuff
that I want to do just I need more time
like the thing is time time kills
everything time is the only thing that I
don't have an unlimited amount of but I
am getting better at organizing my times
so that I have
more time to do what I want to do it
will get better eventually
alright so thank you everybody so much
for watching this reading your comments
I really appreciate everyone's comments
and also I'm gonna be trying to reply to
more people in the comments section
below again it's a time thing like what
do I want to spend my time on what can I
afford to spend my time on so that I can
make sure that everything gets done into
time in the manner and I've been
sticking to the schedule fairly well
it's just that today technical problems
got in the way and everything got moved
for it I had to work on stuff early this
morning it's a big spiel no excuse
they're gonna stick to eight and twelve
every day it's been pretty good about
that I will make sure that stays from
now on so thank you everybody so much
for watching
and then remember write your comments
down in the comment section below for
what you want read in the next video
thanks again everybody and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye